bienvenue à la notice ne tour d'horizon
des jantes et du monde sportif
lebron james a eu maille à partir avec
l'une des rares femmes à avoir eu droit
à assister au match entre les offres et
les lakers à atlanta le comportement
outrancier de celle qu'on a surnommé
corde raide qu'eren a forcé les arbitres
a momentanément arrêté le jeu alors que
l'invectivé lebron avant d'être expulsé
la carène des lignes de côté a eu ce
qu'il voulait cent quinze minutes de
gloire est français comme carole je
pense mme carroll si vous savez pas
c'est quoi une carène
c'est ça tient and mining tsx et aim
d'audience moussa mara voulais juste
défense hautes chaumes
c'est tout ce qu'elle voulait quatre
jours plus tard lebron james a déclaré
qu'en raison de la pandémie il avait
zéro intérêt et zéro énergie à mesure qu
a participé au match des étoiles qui
aura lieu cette année oui-oui à attentes
d'après moi you should peur d'en croiser
car rien de cette année à montréal chez
wever a joué son 1000e match dans la
ligue nationale et le kennedy au disney
de l'honorer en faisant totalement
abstraction qu on est en bas débit ou
eva a pris le temps de saluer la foule
du centre bell alors qu'on sait très
bien qu'ils ignorent personnes dans
l'aréna et que le bruit de la foule
c'est d'un technicien confesseur
super beau support on égoutte remarquer
que le goût du super bowl
c'était marc il aurait dit vendredi et
rob ranck à ce qu'ils sont totalement
conscients du fait qu'ils ne sont plus
des humains mais des mimes en devenir à
chaque instant même leurs deux
conjointes ont repris après la victoire
des votes le bad boy for life dont on
vous a parlé il ya quelques semaines
mais le mime la soirée revient
certainement aux canadiens de week-end
avec le 3 secondes de plus viral de
l'année
tout le monde au fait une blague avec ça
mais moi j'ai fait la mère mon tweet
c'est une joke s'est fait que
pratiquement tous avec ses salades à
part ça s'est passé pour que ce genre 5
ce sera toi une cinquantaine de la clt
si elle sert en fait la même blague que
mois plus tard gritti je peux pas sentir
ma face cachée avec toi surtout depuis
que tu te prends pour rose dans le
meilleur film canadien l'histoire
titanic james cameron céline dion des
icebergs au large de terre-neuve la 7e
victoire tom brady au super bowl non
seulement confirmé comme le meilleur
footballeur de l'histoire mais la
question
cette semaine c'est un style plus grands
sportifs de tous les temps
c'est un débat qu'on veut avoir c'est un
débat qu'on peut voir à lille gordon
federer sur une ambrée dit mettez vous à
tout ce monde là dans une arène à
langueux games après quatre manches de
son premier match en australie de leur
chapeau valeur a ressenti un besoin des
punaises
or comme l'arbitré refusait de le
laisser aller aux toilettes
chapeau pipi monde je t'écris chapeau
pipi a proposé de le faire dans une
bouteille explique peu pâlot toilettes
et à la première occasion
il se prend une gorgée d'eau parlant
tennis mon collègue antoine des eu la
brillante idée de couvrir les
internationaux d'australie deux nuits à
partir de greenfield park
après deux semaines de nuit blanche je
m'attends à ce qu'ils aient enfin l'air
pauvre est de la sagouine
c'est exactement lui mais est bien ça
guen ne s'est pas antoine c'est tout
pour nous merci d'avoir été là et si
vous partagez la capsule
on vous jure pour vraie loque c'est la
dernière fois qu'on parle de tomber ils
filent fini n'oubliez pas pour applaudir
partager la vidéo chat
[Musique]